one they pay attention to others enough
to know when we are sad or angry even
when we don't think we are showing it to
they never forget the importance of
playing and having fun even when they
are all grown up three they value
simplicity they don't need much to have
fun they don't even really need anyone
else sometimes the simplest things can
be a full day's worth of fun before they
know how to relax if they're tired they
just lie down and take a nap wherever
they might be without feeling guilty
about it five they love unconditionally
no matter what kind of day it is or what
kind of mistakes we may have made they
loved us and want to spend time with us
just the same every day six they share
they know that even their favorite toy
is more fun when shared with others 7
they love going outside staying active
and exploring the world they recognize
that there's always something new and
exciting to be discovered 8 they don't
overthink or get stressed out over
little things things are just the way
they are and they're more than willing
to accept what they cannot change 9 they
learn from their mistakes without
getting upset they recognize what they
may have done wrong and simply try their
best to do things right the next time 10
they don't hold grudges when we
accidentally step on their tail they
know that accidents happen and to always
forgive and move on 11 they don't let
things in the past ruin their experience
of the present every moment is a new
moment and they adapt to new conditions
as they come twelve they are happy and
enjoy life even though they have no idea
what's going on they don't need to know
where they came from or where they might
be going they don't need all the answers
they're just happy they're here 13 they
appreciate what they have even if a
leash a fence or a front doors in their
way they don't care they appreciate and
make the absolute most out of what they
have without always wanting more 14 they
do not judge black or white male or
female religious or atheist gay or
straight rich or poor famous or
unpopular none of it matters we are who
we are to them and if we love them they
love us
thank you for watching if he found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder